نقلت مصادر التركيه للجزيره ان وفد روسيا
برئاسه المبعوث الروسي الى سوريا
اليكساندر لبن سيرين سيصلوا انقره يوم
الجمعه لمناقشه الخيارات شمال سوريا
اكد وزير الخارج الروسي سلبي لافروض ان
بلاده ستعمل على ضمان منعي اي اعتداءات
على وحده اراضي سوريا واضاف خلال مشاركته
في منتدى قراءات ريماكوز في موسكو انا
روسيا مهتمه بعمليه السنه في الحوار على
اساس اتفاقنا بين تركيا وسوريا
اسكندريه اسكندريه
نحن مهتمون باستئناف الحوار على اساس
اتفاق الظن بين تركيا وسوريا والذي ما
يزال ساريا بين البلدين ويبدو ان
المتطلبات الاساسيه لهذه العمليه قد نضجت
الان من اجل حل قضايا محدده لضمان الامن
على الحدود مع الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
المخاوي في الامنيه المشروعه لتركيا والتي
تعترف بها القياده السوريه